on va maintenant prendre la direction de
moscou où nous attend notre envoyé
spécial julie dongle of bonjour merci
d'être avec nous on va parler de vous
des réactions côté russe car au delà des
sanctions économiques décidées par les
occidentaux des entreprises françaises
occidentale plus généralement décide
aujourd'hui de quitter la russie
oui en tout à fait un depuis maintenant
plusieurs heures plusieurs entreprises
ont signalé qu'elle allait soit quitter
la russie soit quitter leur partenariat
avec des entreprises russes on pense
notamment au groupe suédois volvo qui a
décidé bien de suspendre la fabrication
de poids lourds sur le territoire russe
et vous venez de le dire plusieurs
géants européens ou occidentale de
l'énergie ont décidé de suspendre leur
participation avec des gros bruce on
pense notamment à bp un le groupe
britannique qui sous pression du
gouvernement anglais a vendu sa
participation dans le groupe russe
rosneft qui est le deuxième producteur
de pétrole russe idem et bien pour le
norvégien et qui nord qui quittent
également roth rau steph même décision
pour le groupe anglo néerlandais shell
qui lui quitte la participation dans gas
trop bas gazprom en revanche est bien le
groupe total energy 1 qui a détient 19
plus de 19% dans l'entreprise russe
novatek à lui pour l'instant maintenu sa
participation dans les groupes russes
malgré bien la pression que d'autres
groupes quitté entreprises russes il a
décidé en revanche de suspendre sa
participation dans des projets d'avenir
est ici et bien en russie bien sûr cela
fait réagir seul arrêt fait réagir au
plus haut sommet de l'état puisque le
premier ministre russe mirel mouche
michou stinat excusez moi a indiqué
qu'il allait prendre un décret pour
interdire aux entreprises occidentales
de quitter la participation dans le
groupe russe une réaction au sommet de
l'état vous le disiez julie d'un golf
comment les russes réagi style à ses
sanctions économiques prises par
l'occident est-ce qu'ils ont peur des
conséquences pour leur pays
alors on ne peut pas parler de mouvement
de panique ici notamment dans les rues
de moscou est loin loin de là il ya une
inquiétude c'est certain qui monte au
fur et à mesure que les gens commencent
réalisé et bien l'ampleur des sanctions
et donc les l'ampleur des changements à
venir pour leur pays et donc pour leur
vie quotidienne
le rouble a battu des records il est en
chute libre ce qui fait bien sûr
considérablement monter les prix
certains confrères ont pu observer des
files d'attentes devant les banques ce
n'est pas le cas de notre équipe mme
harel alameda oui et moi nous n'avons
pas pu constater ce qui nous fait dire
que c'est un mouvement mineur puisque
nous avons fait un grand tour dans la
ville de moscou donc pas de longues
files d'attentes devant les
distributeurs même si certains confrères
à ont pu eux ont pu le constater on a vu
notamment et bien des jeunes gens qui se
ruaient sur les marques occidentales de
vêtements notamment pour acheter par
exemple un jeune homme acheté 5 jean
aussi jean de peur que bien que ces deux
grandes ancienne ferme on a vu des gens
qui travaillaient dans l'industrie de
l'électronique et bien qu'ils se
précipitaient sur des grandes marques
occidentales pour acheter ordinateurs
téléphones portables ou autres
l'inquiétude et les principalement chez
la jeunesse russe cette jeunesse qui est
née après la chute de l'urss qui a connu
un pays moderniser qu'ils aient
l'impression qu'aujourd'hui leur payer
bien émis au bond du monde avec bien
cette interdiction de la russie des
grandes compétitions internationales
avec on voit des chefs d'orchestre qui
sont interdits de spectacles dans le
monde entier bref il ya une grande
inquiétude d'un retour en arrière d'un
rideau de fer qui se baissent à nouveau
en revance dans la vieille génération
soutient plutôt majoritairement vladimir
poutine et on estime bien que ces
sanctions économiques et leurs
conséquences sont le prix à payer pour
la pour la liberté oui beaucoup
d'inquiétudes chez les jeunes un peu
moins peut-être pour la vieille
génération vous nous disiez il faut dire
qu'ils ont une une vision très
parcellaire de la situation car beaucoup
de russes s'informent grâce aux chaînes
d'état russe
oui à tout à fait ses chaînes mais
d'état russe et bien qu'ils tiennent les
verbatim du kremlin par exemple le mot
guerre est toujours interdite sur ses
chaînes de télévision parle d'opérations
spéciales on parle même parfois
d'opérations spéciales à but humanitaire
pour qualifier les combats qui ont lieu
actuellement en ukraine la douma le
parlement russe prépare une loi
punissant de 15 ans raison les gens qui
ne respecteraient pas c'est ces termes à
savoir qu'ils utiliseraient le mot
guerre il y a quelques jours et bien des
journalistes une dizaine de médias était
menacé d'être bloqués ou s'il ne
supprimez pas le contenu où il faisait
état de la guerre en ukraine où vous
vous voyez un peu l'état d'information
de ces grandes chaînes de télévision
russie on a pris le temps de regarder un
peu ce qui se disait très concrètement
sur ses chaînes notamment dans un grand
show qui est très regardé le 60 minutes
de la journaliste
olga ce cas qu'est ayéva pour vous
donner un exemple quand elle parle du
peuple ukrainien elle parle de
nationalistes ou encore de fasciste et
est systématiquement l'ukraine est
présenté comme l'agresseur et non pas
comme l'agressé un autre show qui est
très regardé par les russes lui fait
état d'une haine des occidentaux n'ont
pas à l'égard du peuple russe pour
galvaniser un peu cette cette propagande
du du kremlin donc très difficile pour
les personnes âgées d'avoir une réelle
vision de ce qui est en train de se
passer dans le pays voisin en revanche
est bien la jeunesse russe nous dit que
pour s'informer ils s'abonnent à des
boucles sur le réseau de messagerie
télégramme ou quelques journalistes
indépendants continuent à publier des
informations qu'il est qu'ils disent
avoir vérifié merci beaucoup julie
dongle off pour cet éclairage depuis
moscou merci à vous et bonne journée